hello class of 2015 I am so honored to
be here today
Dean Khurana faculty parents and most
especially graduating students thank you
so much for inviting me the senior class
committee it's genuinely one of the most
exciting things I've ever been asked to
do I have to admit primarily because I
can't deny it as it was leaked in the
WikiLeaks release of the Sony hack that
when I was invited I replied and I
directly quote my own email wow this is
so nice
I'm gonna need some funny ghost writers
any ideas
this initial response now blessedly
public was from the knowledge that at my
class day we were lucky enough to have
Will Ferrell as class day speaker and
that many of us hungover or even freshly
hi mainly wanted to laugh so I have to
admit that today even 12 years after
graduation I'm still insecure about my
own worthiness I have to remind myself
today you are here for a reason
today I feel much like I did when I came
to Harvard Yard as a freshman in 1999
when you guys were two my continued
shock and horror still in kindergarten I
felt like there had been some mistake
that I wasn't smart enough to be in this
company and that every time I opened my
mouth I would have to prove I wasn't
just a dumb actress so I start with an
apology this won't be very funny I'm not
a comedian and I didn't get a
ghostwriter but I am here to tell you
today Harvard is giving you all diplomas
tomorrow you are here for a reason
sometimes your insecurities and your
inexperience may lead you to to embrace
other people's expectations standards or
values but you can harness that
inexperience to carve out your own path
one that is free of the burden of
knowing how things are supposed to be a
path that is defined by its own
particular set of reasons
the other day I went to an amusement
park with my soon-to-be four-year-old
son and I watched him play arcade games
he was incredibly focused throwing his
ball at the target Jewish mother that I
am i skipped 20 steps and was already
imagining him as a major league player
with what is his aim and his arm and his
concentration but then I realized that
when he won he was playing to trade in
his tickets for the crappy plastic toys
the prize was much more exciting than
the game to get it I of course wanted to
urge him to take joy in the challenge of
the game the improvement upon practice
the satisfaction of doing something well
and even feeling the accomplishment when
achieving the game's goals but all of
these aspects were shaded by the little
10-cent plastic men with sticky stretchy
blue arms that adhere to the walls that
that was the prize in a child's nature
we see many of our own innate tendencies
I saw myself in him and perhaps you do
to prizes serve as false idols
everywhere
prestige wealth fame power you will be
exposed to many of these if not all of
course part of why I was invited to come
speak today beyond my being a proud alum
is that I've accrued some very coveted
toys in my life including a not so
plastic not so crappy won an Oscar so we
bump up against a common trope I think
of the commencement address people who
have achieved a lot telling you that the
fruits of achievement are not always to
be trusted but I think that
contradiction can be reconciled and is
in fact instructive achievement is
wonderful when you know why you're doing
it and when you don't know it can be a
terrible trap I went to a public high
school on Long Island Syosset High
School who hello said the girls I went
to school with had Prada bags and flat
ironed hair and they spoke with an
accent I who would move there at age 9
from Connecticut mimic to fit in Florida
oranges chocolate cherries since I'm
ancient and the internet was just
starting when I was in
school people didn't really pay that
much attention to the fact that I was an
actress I was known mainly at school for
having a backpack bigger than I was and
always having whiteout on my hands as I
hated seeing anything crossed out in my
notebooks I was voted for my senior
yearbook most likely to be a contestant
on Jeopardy whore code for nerdiest when
I got to Harvard just after the release
of Star Wars Episode one I knew I would
be starting over in terms of how people
viewed me
I feared people would assume I'd gotten
in just for being famous and that they
would think I was not worthy of the
intellectual rigor here and they would
not have been far from the truth when I
came here I had never written a 10 page
paper before I'm not even sure I'd
written a five page paper I was alarmed
and intimidated by the calm eyes of
fellow students who came here from
Dalton or Exeter who thought that
compared to high school the workload
here was easy I was completely
overwhelmed and thought that reading a
thousand pages a week was unimaginable
that writing a 50 page thesis was just
something I could never do
I had no ideas how to declare I had no
idea how to declare my intentions I
couldn't even articulate them to myself
I'd been acting since I was 11
but I thought acting was too frivolous
and certainly not meaningful I came from
a family of academics and was very
concerned with being taken seriously in
contrast to my inability to declare
myself on my first day of orientation
freshman year five separate students
introduce themselves to me by saying I'm
going to be President remember I told
you that
their names for the record were Bernie
Sanders Marco Rubio Ted Cruz Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton in all
seriousness I believed every one of them
their bearing and self confidence alone
seemed proof of their prophecy where I
couldn't shake my self-doubt I got in
only because I was famous this was how
others saw me it was how I saw myself
driven by these insecurities I decided
that I was going to find something to do
at Harvard that was serious and
meaningful that would change the world
and make it a better place at the age of
18 I had already been acting for seven
years and assumed I'd find a more
serious and profound path in college so
freshman fall I decided to take
neurobiology and advanced modern Hebrew
literature because I was serious and
intellectual needless to say I should
have failed both I got B's for your
information and to this day every Sunday
I burn a small effigy to the pagan gods
of Great Inflation but as I was fighting
my way through Olivet Yahshua in Hebrew
and the different mechanisms of neural
response
I saw friends around me writing papers
on sailing and pop culture magazines and
professors teaching classes on fairy
tales and the matrix I realized that
seriousness for serious is seriousness
is sake was its own kind of trophy and a
dubious one opposed I sought to counter
some half imagined argument about who I
was there was a reason I was an actor I
love what I do and I saw from my peers
and my mentors that that was not only an
acceptable reason it was the best reason
when I got to my graduation sitting
where you sit today after four years of
trying to get excited about something
else
I admitted to myself that I couldn't
wait to go back and make more films I
wanted to tell stories to imagine the
lives of others and help others do the
same
I had found or perhaps reclaimed my
reason you have a prize now or at least
you will tomorrow the prize is a Harvard
degree in your hand but what is your
reason behind it my Harvard degree
represents for me the curiosity and
invention that were encouraged here
the friendships I've sustained the way
professor Graham told me not to describe
the way light hit a flower but rather
the shadow that the flower cast the way
professor scary talked about theater as
a transformative religious force how
professor Coughlin showed how much of
our visual cortex is activated just by
imagining now granted these things don't
necessarily help me answer the most
common questions I'm asked what designer
are you wearing what's your fitness
regime any makeup tips but I have never
since been embarrassed to myself ask
what I might previously have thought was
a stupid question my Harvard degree and
other awards are emblems of the
experiences which led me to them the
wood-paneled lecture halls the colorful
fall leaves the hot vanilla Toscanini 'z
reading great novels and overstuffed
library chairs running through dining
halls screaming whoo ahh city stuff city
stuff city steps cities death it's easy
now to romanticize my time here but I
had some very difficult times here too
some combination of being 19 dealing
with my first heartbreak taking birth
control pills that have since been taken
off the market for their depressive side
effects and spending too much time
missing daylight during winter months
led me to some pretty dark moments
particularly during sophomore year there
were several occasions I started crying
in meetings with professors overwhelmed
with what I was supposed to pull off
when I could barely get myself out of
bed in the morning moments when I took
on the motto for my school work done not
good
if only I could finish my work even if
it took eating a jumbo pack of Sour
Patch Kids to get me through a single 10
page paper I felt that I had
accomplished a great feat I'd repeat to
myself done not good a couple of years
ago I went to Tokyo with my husband and
I ate at the most remarkable sushi
restaurant I don't even eat fish I'm
vegan so that tells you how good it was
even with just vegetables this sushi was
the stuff you dream about the restaurant
had six seats my husband and I marveled
at how anyone could make rice so
superior
to all other rice we wondered why they
didn't make a bigger restaurant and be
the most popular place in town our local
friends explained to us that all the
best restaurants in Tokyo are that small
and do only one type of dish sushi or
tempura or teriyaki because they want to
do that thing well and beautifully and
it's not about quantity it's about
taking pleasure in the perfection and
beauty of the particular I'm still
learning now that it's about good and
maybe never done that the joy and work
ethic and virtuosity we bring to the
particular can impart a singular type of
enjoyment to those we give to and of
course to ourselves in my professional
life it also took me time to find my own
reasons for doing my work the first film
I was in came out in 1994 again
appallingly the year most of you were
born I was 13 years old upon the film's
release and I can still quote what the
New York Times said about me
verbatim miss Portman poses better than
she acts the film had a universally
tepid critical response and went on to
bomb commercially that film was called
the professional or Lian in Europe and
today 20 years and 35 films later it is
still the film people approached me
about the most to tell me how much they
loved it how much it moved them how it's
their favorite movie I feel lucky that
my first experience releasing a film was
initially such a disaster by all
standard measures I learned early that
my meaning had to be from the experience
of making the film and the possibility
of connecting with individuals rather
than the foremost trophies in my
industry financial and critical success
and also that those initial reactions
could be false predictors of your works
ultimate legacy I started choosing only
jobs I was passionate about and from
which I knew I could glean meaningful
experiences this thoroughly confused
everyone around me agents producers and
audiences alike
I made Goya's ghost a foreign
independent film and studied art history
visiting the Prado every day for four
months as I read about Goya and the
Spanish Inquisition
I made V for Vendetta studio action
movie for which I learned everything I
could about freedom fighters who
other eyes might be called terrorists
from Menachem Begin to The Weather
Underground
I made your highness a pot head comedy
with Danny McBride and laughed for three
months straight I was able to own my
meaning and not have it be determined by
box office receipts or prestige by the
time I got to making Black Swan the
experience was entirely my own I felt
immune to the worst things anyone could
say or write about me under whether an
audience felt like going to see my movie
or not I was instructed for me to see
that ballet dancers for ballet dancers
once your technique gets to a certain
level the only thing that separates you
from others is your quirks or even flaws
one ballerina was famous for how she
turned slightly off balance you can
never be the best technically someone
will always have a higher jump or more
beautiful line the only thing you can be
the best at is developing your own self
authoring your own experience was very
much what Black Swan itself was about I
worked with Darren Aronofsky the film's
director to change my last line in the
movie - it was perfect because my
character Nina is only artistically
successful when she finds perfection and
pleasure for herself not when she's
trying to be perfect in the eyes of
others so when Black Swan was successful
financially and I began receiving
accolades I felt honored and grateful to
have connected with people but the true
core of my meaning I had already
established and I needed it to be
independent of people's reactions to me
people told me that Black Swan was an
artistic risk a scary challenge to try
to perforate portray a professional
ballet dancer but it didn't feel like
courage or daring that drew me to it
I was so oblivious to my own limits that
I did things I was woefully unprepared
to do and so the very inexperienced that
in college had made me feel insecure and
made me want to play by others rules now
was making me actually take risks I
didn't even realize were risks when
Darren asked me if I could do ballet I
told him that I was basically a
ballerina which by the way I
wholeheartedly believed when it quickly
became clear and preparing for the film
that I was maybe 15 years away from
being a ballerina it made me work a
million times harder and of course the
magic of cinema and body doubles helped
the final effect but the point is if I
had known my own limitations I never
would have taken the risk and the risk
led to one of my greatest artistic and
personal experiences and that I not only
felt completely free I also met my
husband during filming similarly I just
directed my first film a tale of love
and darkness and was quite blind to the
challenges ahead of me the film is a
period film completely in Hebrew in
which I also act with an eight-year-old
child as a co-star all of these are
challenges as should have been terrified
of as I was completely unprepared for
them but my complete ignorance as to my
own limitations
looked like confidence and got me into
the director's chair once there I had to
figure it all out and my belief that I
could handle these things contrary to
all evidence of my ability to do so was
half the battle
the other half was very hard work the
experience was the deepest and most
meaningful one of my career now clearly
I'm not urging you to go perform heart
surgery without the knowledge to do so
making movies admittedly has less
drastic consequences than most
professions and allows for a lot of
effects that make up for mistakes the
thing I'm saying is make use of the fact
that you don't doubt yourself too much
right now as we get older we get more
realistic and that gets and that
includes about our own abilities or lack
thereof and that realism does us no
favors
people always talk about diving into
things you're afraid of that never
worked for me if I'm afraid I run away
and I would probably urge my child to do
the same fear protects us in many ways
what has served me is diving into my own
obliviousness being more confident than
I should be which everyone tends to
decry in American kids and those of us
who have been great inflated and ego
inflated well it can be a good thing if
it makes you try things you never might
have tried your inexperience is an asset
and will allow you to think an original
unconventional ways
except your lack of knowledge and use it
as your asset I know a famous violinist
who told me that he can't compose
because he knows too many pieces so when
he starts thinking of a note an existing
piece immediately comes to mind just
starting out one of your biggest
strengths is not knowing how things are
supposed to be you can compose freely
because your mind isn't cluttered with
too many pieces and you don't take for
granted the way things are the only way
you know how to do things is your own
way
you hear we'll all go on to achieve
great things there is no doubt about
that each time you set out to do
something new your inexperience can
either lead you down a path where you
will conform to someone else's values or
you can forge your own path even if you
don't realize that's what you're doing
if your reasons are your own your path
even if it's a strange and clumsy path
will be wholly yours and you will
control the rewards of what you do by
making your internal life fulfilling at
the risk of sounding like a Miss America
contestant the most fulfilling things
I've experienced have truly been the
human interactions spending time with
women and village banks in Mexico with
finca microfinance organization meeting
young women who were the first and only
in their communities to attend secondary
school in rural Kenya with free the
children a group that build sustainable
schools in developing countries trekking
with gorillas conservationists in Rwanda
it's a cliche because it's true that
helping others ends up helping you more
than anyone getting out of your own
concerns and caring about someone else's
life for a while reminds you that you
are not the center of the universe and
that in the ways we are generous or not
we can change the course of someone's
life even at work the small feats of
kindness crew members directors fellow
actors have shown me have had the most
lasting impact and of course first and
foremost the center of my world is the
love I share with my family and friends
I wish for you that your friends will be
with you through it all as my friends
from Harvard have been together since we
graduated my friends from school are
still very cool
we have nursed each other through
heartaches and danced at each other's
weddings we've held each other at
funerals and rocked each other's new
babies we've worked together on projects
helped each other get jobs and thrown
parties for when we've quit bad ones and
now our children are creating a second
generation of friendship as we look at
them toddling together Haggard and
disheveled working parents that we are
grab the good people around you don't
let them go the biggest asset this
school offers you is a group of peers
that will be both your family and your
school for life I remember always being
pissed at the spring here in Cambridge
tricking us into remembering a sunny
yard full of laughing three frisbee
throwers after eight months or dark
frigid library dwelling it was like the
school had managed to turn on the good
weather is the last memory we should
keep in mind that would make us want to
come back but as I get farther away from
my years here I know that the power of
this school is much deeper than weather
control it changed the very questions I
was asking to quote one of my favorite
thinkers Abraham Joshua Heschel to be or
not to be is not the question the vital
question is how to be and how not to be
thank you I can't wait to see how you do
all the beautiful things you will do